that's another nuclear program wait for
that to talk to me all right you see
starting stream I like when I see that
we are live so you know what and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
and the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 136 and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day I'm very excited about
our special guest and we've got Phil's
for instance comments on VR half-life
Alex stadia refunds and Black Friday to
discuss so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce a lawyer who is not
only a solid frame to the realm but it's
truly one of the most passionate and
energetic content creators within our
YouTube community whether it be his
presence at the biggest gaming
conventions detailed unboxings or
hilarious game streams all done were
positively and that classic New York
field
introducing the created host of the 108
Dragons YouTube to TV channel and
panelist of the GOG podcast the right
hand of Zeus and neighborhood tech head
but we'll still Billy Rock or any block
through its fighters and making his
debut into the realm of the lords mommy
Lord la Mateus aka runaway dragons TV
how are you doing sir life is good baby
I'm happy to be here long overdue you
already know you had that eleven in a
building there what you been playing
there what's going on
life is good man after that introduction
I know you was talking really Call of
Duty doubt man
yesterday I would love to play after
party already know we got the Lord
addict bags from ransom whether work had
a Monday you know so it might not be
joining us today
but hopefully we get the brother back in
next week so send your shoutouts to Lord
you already know but of course we still
got three horsemen in the round those
original Lords at the round table of
course the most technical gaming Lord a
solo game who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also
disaster Damas mr. awful high-profile
Illuminati and Lord patron of the iron
bake my man Lord sovereign are you doing
sir
did a good man good morning gentlemen
good morning because that's coming soon
yeah
and a couple more weeks all of my
Sundays pray like the bushes to be in
the bushes I want the water [ __ ] or get
nothing man I had a little bit of time
off this week so I actually sat down to
play some stuff but I didn't play
anything new message
what am I gonna play hmm and I just go
back which is AC Odyssey I'll claim a CI
yeah
that game is too much Thank You soo much
I turned it on and as I get is more new
content what all that Atlanta stuff
that's all brand-new not but you know
that game still kind of amazes me every
time I turn it on like some of the visas
in a game like yeah on a beach just
looking at the water like that game yeah
I saw what you talking about because you
know how you go and you look at your
updates what updated I'm looking at what
updated and I'm like man that updated in
this game it's so much content but it's
not even funny man yeah it's grinding
away at that little bit little by little
I'm trying to get into I'm not in the
console streaming of bait well I'm in
crowd but not in console streaming so I
have to do that so I have access to my
to my library so I can actually be
moving again I got out of it because I
was afraid of bird that is my y'all
ready for preview program guys like that
right yeah you got your little question
is your little quizzes over and don't
don't even do it that's how they brick
that's how they break my call of I was
really not you know what I'm not on my
system break I'm good they compensate me
for that we already know how you do like
I said I told you
shout out to my mom much better half
yesterday was 6-year anniversary how we
do i was surprising her to take her to
go see Aladdin right thing is my sister
he sent a group text to both of us
saying happy anniversary love you guys
right I didn't realize it was a group
text so I'm thinking she's texting me i
text my sister dinner do we really need
to have so she's coming in hot
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the XS gamer ooh
the lord of combat sports king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
their premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir hold
on hold on let's let's let's let's let's
turn that Megatron around shout to luna
jane lane with the $2 super chair please
put something in the chat so we can
shout you out brother or so what's going
on that megan always was it oh man did
you see the BBC in the promos that i'll
be putting up with them something let me
tell you how the process go my soul
cockney nobility let me get the picture
of what's gonna go up because i give him
the synapses so he finds out what's
going on he's like oh he can't for it
right so he goes to the website and he
writes up all the stuff he does
everything and then i sent him the
picture so he gets the pitch federal
Janek in the face right so they go up
then he gets the video so then the video
goes through its process and you know i
usually put a video that's up that's um
palatable for all ages right so the
music is really you know geared towards
all ages according to according to lord
the lord said that they say they're
weighing about going to youtube but
continue but then promo beats the promo
beats me so far so i usually throw it on
instagram so if y'all want to go see
where the promo beats is that it's on
the instagram and if you ever give a
comment that you watch the video i send
you out the promo with the beats and the
judge it's nice that some joint that you
can bump in your car something like that
so yeah so this week what i've been
playing this boy on that x cloud
[Music]
it's anyone walking in the street and
you wouldn't you like it's crazy cuz I'm
gonna run across the street and get body
[Laughter]
I told you guys the road map everybody's
like what's the power of the cloud will
the power to cloud is there now now we
talk for the power to class
the third was all crackdown if you to
power to cloud for one little game for
crackdown crackdown with the power to
cloud duped it really happened to you
but you didn't see it when it was coming
down and then they you know what they
mean would charge you they just hit you
with their cuz they got that work so
that you here take that
like them fill every company I go to a
sink they launch when you look about
remember you remembers resume being at
the companies right yet that he was at
the helm now of three of the worst
launches ever in the history you do off
rip what he had the shoes order he was
kid of to sink another cover wholly is
to destroy I want you to be honest with
this guy the bigger the bank account the
bigger the destruction right the bank
account is crazy large you know coming
in geez wreck shop it was gonna be lit
from the go yo y'all got nothing nothing
that was promised in the Box I saw how
they got a play on PC that you gotta be
Wyatt with the freedom freedom so listen
anyway just get back to the real field
field ominous Maximus kimchi the real
Phyllis about his words he about
business everybody I don't want a friend
King wool friend is he he's cool friend
is he he's just doing it with a smile
you don't like the smell me neither
I don't like more boxes to have a smell
Cognito knows that I never liked you
Shane Mosley I don't like Sugar Ray
Leonard all these guys would have smile
but the assassins though like they
really do their business so I have to
get I have to bend the knee to fill and
understand that Phil is not going to be
the Mike Tyson to the situation yeah hit
like my Tyson but he won't see a smile
he'd be nice with it does he want
inclusion he wants his product on your
product if you want sell go ahead just
make sure you pumping install
you'll be soaking in Europe yes sir
the only cold in the pop yeah he see in
you know and that's exactly what he's
about Phil is about inclusion he's not
trying to stop your flow he's not trying
to do anything he adjoint he just wanted
to make it pop for everybody so I'm
playing it some so do ask me this is why
it got so crazy cuz they do ask me and
he saw me playing it in the street in a
[ __ ]
I wasn't even a wife I do know what you
playing cuz he saw like this contraption
I'm walking with the contraption show
love today yeah that's what's that oh yo
Xbox library what I'm playing Halo 5 can
I touch it
so how much does this cost how much does
you have Xbox he said yeah I say you
have game past he said I said it's free
you know what
play with me oh yes I say make sure that
you sign up whatever and go look and see
I said download the app right now he'd
download the app right now and it says
ready to start streaming mmm
you say yo you just put me on right now
people look at you're crazy like I've
been I was in the doctor's office with
it and people like your xbox you crazy
different let me tell you what I was
playing as we go sir yes okay all right
so I finished out of worlds nice only
botched two missions okay all right so
basically got a hundred percent complete
I think I got one of the best and
there's I think what I like about it is
it goes through all your choices at the
end and it tells you about every
character that you interacted with
I got all five of the secret characters
out I kept them from beginning to end
and I did all the day's side missions so
you know I'm one of those people that
try to like dig in and get everything
out of the game is really fun yeah it
was really good it wasn't like no go
fetch it type of mission so I felt
pretty clean with it all right
um I started my resume evil - and if
y'all go inside the Xbox store right now
yeah I got it for a good price yeah it
is $19.99 and Xbox also I played
Darkstalkers three okay and I went back
and I started back on my Zelda on my
switch
what whoa okay well okay so it's now
happen right for my boy my boy is like
um no my son need a switch for Christmas
and I don't got the bread right now and
the Black Friday deal but you talk about
Black Friday it was no Black Friday
beyond those switches Nintendo don't
handle black for the $2.99 I said that's
not a deal they don't ever lower the
prices for nobody
so you can get a Wii U right now for
$5.99 real price he was like yeah but I
don't have the bread right now and get
paid until Wednesday Sasa
know what I got you so I um I went home
picked it up at PC Rich's pick this
joint up doctor picking it up stop fraud
no knees dude Benna me give it to the
switc action but definitely 100% it's it
we had all-time high like lemon what I
like about Xbox chat right
have 12 people in there four of them
probably doing the same game together to
probably doing another games together
and everybody else is playing other
games but we having a conversation like
we all in the same room in the back and
[Laughter]
also being happy that they gave them a
perfect did you know me Lord kognito
spread never listen to rum ILP not
telling what you want to hear but what
you need to hear so for me it's about
that had to get the dragon marriage baby
had to bring it back did not copy yeah
yeah I was fraud right you'll put the
fro delight in for charity I was born I
was fraud no-name Kickstarter I would
throw it all the way to the very end
sounds like it was too many for gazing
situations even though you
and then Friday I had to do this game
don't look bad the jacket is individual
item is that all one big texture you
could change shirts yo y'all right now
if y'all grew up like lemon know y'all
grew up back in the day with them old
school sure brother karate flicks that's
what I'm talking about
you know saying like this is the essence
today this is literally video game show
brothers you know say just whatever you
do put on the Japanese voice English
actors run loose on your Shenmue they
will ruin your shin who do not hate hey
there no cut that hair that none of that
you want the Nichkhun on you want that
you know so that's so the little kitty
ran up on a little kid there was animes
and you know shout out to the NPC's just
looking horrible what are you doing in
here put the Japanese voice actors
almost wanna be the English aren't just
for the turn
so don't worry you throw that game right
in the bushes did you do that
so that's right this is shout out I
finally stopped running cop that symbol
for it on a ps4 Pro nice the only thing
with them dos off is like max is 1080p
[Music]
you know like in the 40s 50s and then
you spike the boom she's weird spikes
your anima du Coq I'm gonna give it to
you kiddo cause it's not my as I thought
you Sookie like he's been in a hole
somewhere and doesn't understand modern
gaming he said no I don't hear what what
new hot stuff is out there and I'm gonna
keep making the game I was making 30
years ago
he's still stuck you know like he liked
her own like that old raffle he still
he's still spitting he think it's the
hottest thing for him but back then it
was fire understanding he just don't
care that's what it is and he doesn't
care
you just modernizing this for anybody
this is this is my vision to the $4
super jet iron laws here to support the
Kings wanna wait my bro
bye bye that's what's up man so you
already know that's pretty much it just
like King said of X cloud all days but
rocking that man in Texas seven and
doing a motion without a world so that's
that so what Lord saw will take care of
the business sir started trying to pay
the bill of course is that time of the
month once again to say thank you to our
patreon subscribers dishing now we have
more subscribers to thank yes cry burrs
will that to the patreon of course we
have a bunch of new people that are are
supporting the Lord's on you too
you know like we said before like like I
did today thank you for joining the road
[Laughter]
all of your content then you see that
join button right next to the subscribe
button which I hope you're subscribed
already join button and you will see
three different tiers of Lord you have
bronze Lord silver and Lord golden Lord
and of course when you come in at the
what is it the bronze level you get
access to all those hot emojis I believe
we'll get one more subscriber one more
we will have access to at least another
couple of emojis we got fire bogeys we
sit down yeah I like the you see
cat-daddy using the pocket watch today
it's a lot of funny was classic io p
cigs use some of that pocket watches I'm
looking at my buckets bucketz thank you
some patron and we get into our Thank
You sumar our YouTube subscribers mm-hmm
so starting off with our boy Jay meds
thank you sir you already know bredrin
we'll be seeing you on the 21st for Star
Wars right yes roundtable with the lower
floor no you know what let me go buy my
tickets right now let's go you are here
with the fro let's put the fraud alert
for sovereign because yeah here exposing
everybody in himself
let's pause him keep going - what you
doing sir Corre lytic aka Lord whisky
forever in our hearts thank you so whole
wash up first of all salute Lord whisky
or IP my brother always
with me you already know we got a salute
to people shout to old schools that all
their Lord always go Tech Talk he's the
good raw bronze Lord so we got the extra
emoji we'll get that done at the end of
the show that ass was so yeah yeah shout
out to Smitty Smith with the file a
super chat got a salute the ILP this
podcast is like family which is a
powerful thing
much love Smitty Smith you already know
your family Osman who copped a purple
nurple on that Black Friday who caught
that purple you definitely get that
bloody red right now I know the arm
what's those dudes the 49 is hot ready
go go get in there
no but salute you shout out the whiskey
again recipes bro no doubt follow it up
by Lorde slow-mo back slap barrel get
all boom in a building fire out a super
jet let's go
best podcasts on Sunday morning part
none it's my pleasure to support the oil
boom thanks my dude hey nobody true-blue
that bull man Neil mentored HB 33 thank
you for the support
followed by Lord Nintendo Direct and of
course rate the Emperor Frey was good oh
thank you sir
and next up we have Lord QX seven
masters I haven't been using anybody's
meaning that you do continue thanks that
we have Lord or fastback 67 68 LG solo
no doubt no doubt thank you sir mhm
next up we have Lord stitch 66 69 this
in the heel of switch toe pumps afford
bagged a bun dough that's my that's my
last word homie yo he always giving me
fry that's my guy
salute of course next up we had a lot of
positivity man is one of the most
positive brothers on Twitter Lord gaming
Forte Forte Forte help your boy slow mo
he out here in these destiny streets man
he left he left home to visit alone and
he left all armed his morning air salut
he came back to the true nor the shooter
that's it so let's support that brother
yogi see the price on division 2 is 12
talking all that this good I told you I
don't forget I got Lords of gaming net
Lord undead 3x VI of gaming except we
have Lord linchpin thank you sir please
faith that's what service the holy and
followed by we have the Lord of X cloud
Lord bill still well no let me tell you
something which I don't really
understand like if somebody hit me in
the chat
it was like I mean India like yo King
man I'm gonna get a hold of that so I
say yes it doesn't you know there's one
of a kind you know type of thing you
know me and car got it was three of a
kind basically and I was like yeah
that's a buck fifty you're like oh stop
pocket watches they got all the
teespring yard that's a different shirt
shirt definitely not from overseas Lord
Sammy Prescott bugs was so dizzy what's
up yes yes next up we have Lord chunk
Lata himself the Lord of brass and of
course the original page and himself
Lord monkey punch always try to take my
Phoenix mirror off off rip already next
up we have the Lord of the stream team
himself and the king of the banhammer
salute my brother lost so much for us
and as well please check out round table
with the stream team or generally on
Mondays when team is focusing on the
community he's got a nice little thing
going
I think salty you weren't here tomorrow
so salute you know and I can't wait to
hang out with them when we go to pax
because you know he definitely brings
that a little extra flavor
he lost out there's a lot of things for
the Lord behind us you salute that
brother no doubt no doubt
and of course next up a family from the
cradle to the grave Lord Coe era himself
joe said he fed up with the father so we
chat good morning and thank you for your
hard work
greetings to all and from mrs. boom
bring that to the airport would you
[Laughter]
Eugene the parking lot nothing to do the
wind say let me get all the most like I
was so humbled to see that III I know
you pulling up so we already know hit me
up it's about your no we do cat - no you
said you coming through any money i pax
- oh you won't be a pax no we won't go
out for that on that lobster night so
you know you know gets it up you know
Boston do that seafood for real
so we're gonna get out there for that
seafood night and we gonna had that
Lobster giggle my man anchorman respond
back to my challenge Thank You Man we
have Lord J Pereira 99 Oh Lord Jameson
that's my mace salute he did an episode
of round to round table yes sir relative
with the Lord I know with the Lord's yes
always never at least leave him across
the fire one of the funniest people in
the room my destiny brother and he did
that a live reaction shoulders he was
absolutely loud you got we're gonna get
you back on the arm live reactions there
so hit me up man we're gonna do another
one we might do that for that Video Game
Awards or something hit me up you
already know and our anchor man says
mandalorian challenge I said let's do it
in the chat the very it was offered yeah
but you gotta help me medium and you're
gonna be doing a whole show
brother yo gotti that situation with our
YouTube I won't say Pete Frates our
YouTube supporters laughs welcome to the
room welcome to the realm thank you so
much for the support guys thank you to
you guys for supporting us on two
different platforms that is fantastic
and amazing thank you so much we really
appreciate it
so let's get into these these shoutouts
first of all Lord Titus right thank you
so much right is Right a family show for
the realm one day the
daddy daddy check the Steam account you
got we got one coming - finally
yes degrees not out quality this because
there's nothing else here Lord Mike
Washington thank you double supporters
Lord guessing himself Lord of the Empire
thank you my lord filly Eagle I'll be
fitted I'll be at eight
next up we have Lord the blue one
thank you so much for the support my
brother the blue one that's one word the
blue of course we have another one of
our double support your Johanns lvj
brother next up we have Lord sleepy
Goblin to deeply thank us a new name
known in the chatter and of course we
have Lord night music thank you so much
for the support my brother
much appreciated then we have my choice
Absolut followed by last but absolutely
not least Lord Stitch 66 69 much love yo
so again thank y'all for that joy button
man really appreciate it
and as you know you got the badges right
now everybody's in a little peasantry
mode with the badge but stay with it
you gonna level up everything has a
level to it you know say you're gonna
see the funny things you gonna level up
the longer you are a member in the
program we got some funny one justice on
deck we got Squires or a deck that's
fine because we got funny little badges
based on the level of dedication in
social Vagabond oh you're late man you
miss you too shout outs but um yeah man
so that that's it on natural solve you
good cuz I would definitely to get this
Wiener you gotta give these giveaways
wrong now to give back to the community
I just can't take dollar gift card
giveaway role please in the winner $10
gift card giveaway is Lord QX 7 master
oh that's no bag has been dropped off
and you know what happened hit that like
what Bobby diamonds mm-hm
no doubt alright let's get into this $20
gift card giveaway 20 K 20 cash that's
where they evil - yeah that's Black
Friday something $20 gift card giveaway
even 40 salut
shoutout to Lord that we cheat no
Dowdell you can't be rigging early I
didn't do [ __ ] you can't be greasing
frogs early like I needed this may be
called first FC Bali whatever brother
good and the winner of our teespring
giveaway Lord slow-mo banging forte is
not gonna be pleased with that before
tell your name gotta being green thank
you once again guys for all the support
I will you're getting at you guys in the
DMS let you know the mm oh you could
tell me what it is that you want but
again thank you okay how Cox said yeah
you got it
[Laughter]
are you good we good the realm is uh the
Romans is good this full please
Littlefinger it's the longest longest
intro an ILP history today bro home yo
real special delicate real quick got um
you know I'll see a long net Lords
gaming Lords gaming dinette y'all make
sure y'all support me go to the website
I'll see grassroots thing start this
thing and the support has been
tremendous man so in case you missed it
previously obviously we know we had some
new Lords of the realm Undead x3 XVI
Lord anchorman and of course Mike P the
truth all contributing to log net but we
got two more Lords in the
another game with Batman so please
welcome
mokmou my brother he's actually at way
it's w8y H I K on Twitter
police eluded me I got an article right
now up on the Disney Plus situation with
Visio Sudanese all the way from Bahrain
y'all Bahrain the Middle East holdin it
down for the Lord salute that brother
tremendous riding experience and he'll
be helping us out with news and tech
pieces so salute Lord Mahmud why salute
brother really appreciate you out here
and one more to the list of course you
know this brother from the TX our
podcast the saltiest gaming podcast and
the shot podcast my bro Lord said Tyrion
the newest member of was a gaming dotnet
you don't saying so yo he is tremendous
man this this kid is he's really smart
he has a lot of passionate gaming
opinions he will be lending his hand
would experience with a lot of game
riding look how full out of his work
shortly so salute to the realm
everybody much appreciate he's building
a nice strong team and we kind of done
it without you everybody kids love loads
of game with that that y'all but yes
that's a mess so we go get into this
show obviously a lot of contributions
and announcements out the way but we
gotta start with the guest of the owl
mom man Lord love me theist in the
building his video game system history
whose journey to create YouTube the one
away dragons TV and of course becoming a
member of the sensational GOG podcast so
mob man Lord lemon let's start from the
very beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had and
what got you the game well before we do
anything let me do this right you know I
don't represent
a mystery man started with pong no I'm
uh my greatest arcade experiences was
fighting streets before back in the days
going to the movie did is playing
Tempest space invaders but this and
that's what that's what God is popping I
like centipede but millipede was my
jumbo millipede with the jump off and we
went into the later rounds of Ninja
Turtles arcade x-men side-scrolling
adventure game one of those very rare
adventure games in the arcade still a
class 'icon today and then you know got
into the 5200 which it really catapulted
graphics over the Atari but those who
don't know then you do visit in
television wars I think oh that's my
first uh let's see a typographic last a
little bit but the prices was crazy you
know that end that Neal gear with a
pricey pricey sir that's you and King
operate that if she would kick talk I
wasn't in there later I was watching
these streets you know I had a Black
Friday with this don't know about
Councilwoman warrants which I like doing
that I don't remember those genesis
commercials with a burst or super
Nintendos out the window yeah yes
Genesis us with the Tendo office
skyscrapers in New York next and
battling commercials a boy would speak
for that next commercial on anything he
beat WH T for you over God but what what
my history showed me man I could sit on
the sidelines and see any game on
another console because I thought what
constable so I bought everything I had
everything to the Tendo switch big
holiday season for them for big games de
ma can excel de Luigi's Mansion and
asked you change all cop dollar it's not
too good for PlayStation this year but
uh I don't do Kevin Costner and a
postman you know I always have every
console Manning and that's just my
history I've always been a multi console
game everybody got a preference but
that's my so you talked about the 5200
but you skimmed over it did you did you
have the Congo Bongo because I had Congo
Bongo did you did you what was the game
for 5200 that you like to know it's not
too many people see when we dig into
people history
now to people any people can go back to
the ground roots like that baby came
yeah let me get that was that that
brought in their arm the multiplayer
what was that game call on the 5200 I
can't think of the damn name it was it
it was a tank game I played like every
day are you talking about the one that
had the double scream and you should be
going through and you can just see you
just the tank talking about Atari
brought it back and he brought it back
for the Jaguar it was called battlezone
like my other big favorite even though I
had the Jag well I like that robot game
and I liked it alien vs. predator yes
when the facehuggers jumped on the
screen everybody jumped up there cheers
yeah true I just wasn't a fan we would
do our systems and our friends around so
we have one friend shoutout to solo
listen he was the only one from the team
that ran out and got the Jaguar so you
know we had my cousin house we in the
basement and he opened up his box now we
knew something was wrong when he opened
up the box and I had to aim when that
happened right so we look Weez like this
doesn't look well it doesn't bode well
for Atari at this point he took it out
and the plastic to look a little cheap
and that little red button did look all
sure but we like you know what they did
say that this is really 16-bit I'll get
into a break so he turned it on he
hooked it up and it was the it was the
worst of your putter
in your friend house as you don't want
to say nothing to him
are you and sob morph said where did you
learn how to drive talk about his
journey right there but I free you
lemming the fact that when you copy you
had it what did you think when you open
the box what did you think I was so
happy to get the system I ain't care how
I came you know what I'm saying I just
wish i was high for a new I was high for
a new uh I'm so hard with like I am what
everything brand new I get a new why I
want to plug it up and see how it's
gonna display these 4k graphics know
through gaming took recommend this
history on that message real quick so
what now we got to talk about that 108
dragons YouTube channel now real quick
tell you a funny story before I actually
met you I didn't even realize I already
watched what are your videos for backing
me cuz I was gonna get that vertigo and
you did it yeah we need that sponsorship
right now for the kid what's going on
but anyway shout out the lemon because I
remember like I needed a big man [ __ ] I
was like I mean I can't be all these
little ex-racer you know say it's to
show off for me so I look I looked up
you know we see big man [ __ ] and your
video came up and I go I even know you
had tried so funny how life work out and
boy we connect you know there afterwards
you know like I like this cat from New
York so tell me about the 108 dragon TV
experience how you got that started well
how well really the name came from my
clan 17 years ago
Xbox and the name originated from the
crime-free and anime the one away that's
where it came from and what we used to
do we still play competitively on game
battles and uh before we had like 107
like Padawans we had learned the history
of what one awake track meant and you
had to watch the whole six series enemy
oh this question dudes
and uh my shadow to my mat the mat gotta
have structure so shout out to my boy 6a
he's a 17 year member he's in the chair
right now he know what it is and we used
to question young Padawans like listen
what happened in this scene it feels you
didn't know and you had to go back and
watch it then he had to tone up the
skills when that first person or either
that Rainbow six level cuz that's when
we really play the vet and Ghost Recon
game yeah it's in history behind that
name people diglettz behind it YouTube
channel so you know being a leader that
I was I just took the Damon to supply my
channel we're gonna keep that movement
papa video 6a says you to really take
that you dish into the YouTube game like
now what made you say okay boy I'm gonna
do this channel thing and get this thing
jumping off like what was the thing that
kind of motivate you to the game now
listen I listen to youtubers you know
first of all about eight years ago my
car parties always play you should do
YouTube I said yeah nobody watching
YouTube you're crazy
like so my wife told me the same thing
you should do you Jemaine when we've
gotten you to I ain't got no time for
that so what happened was I think in
2015 at the 16 I started watching
content creators put out PS information
make the opinions facts um talk about HD
on they can't spell HD on you know I'm
saying I started saying maybe I need to
invest my time into really educated
people
and when I say my opinion it's my teeth
don't make back and you know when you're
real it's harder to get people's
attention then if you do nonsense you
know
shout out to the real man the work I'll
put it your channel your website it's
phenomenal
you know do you think we go out here
just what I'm gonna say today now it
takes researching homework and putting
things together and it's not easy
especially when you've got jobs I don't
live in a basement of my mom's crib just
money out here and that's why everybody
in the chat man support everybody here
because I'm telling y'all do to under 8
it work the chocolate man I see whose
websites I'd be like what is this like a
bunch of thumbnails pay for something
you ain't keeping the people no car tip
but you know that's what it's about
just putting back man very well it's
just like the positive route is always
the slow the slow burn right if we want
to do two clickbait you want to do the
nasty drama we know what to do if we
want to really just make it about that
and just if it's just about views but
what you said which I really appreciate
and one thing I respect from you is that
you know we're we can't come from and
I'm saying see you doing what you're
doing keeping it positive you know I'm
saying that's the aspiring of a cat's
you know I'm saying where we from they
could do the same thing and you could
still win you know I'm saying - I'll
respect you no I'm saying big time and
one thing about you is your passion
brother like you always out in shows you
out there you know saying with the cuz
I'm not mad I'm talking to hip-hop then
I look over you know the voice may sound
like you from New York or whatever the
hell yeah we got downstairs at
Microsoft's event we online are we
kicking a dead from man we kick it that
we kicking it over there
I'm like yo this dude everywhere I'm
like he over there then we go and we
meet people that are you know you know
this dude today listen I'm gonna tell
you right now if y'all think I know your
name on Twitter I don't miss my
personality I'm a face dude so when you
when you don't put your face on to
something I don't respect you
right so when he said y'all got my
channel on runaway dragons or whatever
so hilarious I'm down with this dude
right so that's you know that's from
from me that's where that black brothers
a joint spawn from there cuz I'm like yo
we got a situation and we can work you
know being from New York man from the
Bronx being from Brooklyn black brothers
you know there's a commonality and it
ties if we when he was telling you about
going inside the the movie theater and
playing temptation and doing things of
this nature you don't understand like
everybody has a story
facts right and all of our stories are
almost simulate we do in this age
bracket yes we were doing the same
things is the same passion the same love
so when what like he said he started his
channel because he was listening to
people with false information and fraud
and out here that because everybody was
telling him to do it before them they
saw the natural talent in him before
them he's like man but what had to move
him was all the faith fraud people out
here with them look he knows he can be
and win we all know what to do that's
why I love what you said you know gril
subscribed him that's why I messed with
them that's why we told all that stuff
you see his statues in the front
this is really for you oh that would be
when he jumps into parties with us right
he no I know what you don't know you
play destiny more than destiny play
destiny
okay back in the building perfect yes
way you know say so why don't we got
that out the way now again a lot of
people also know you from that amazing
gog pocket oh yes
oh yeah so let's get to that man how did
you link it with K Meghan them boys
bloody I see him in a chat as well you
know that panel man damn it started with
that boy war honey
he saw me with some frauds you
surrounded by clowns you need to come
rock with some real dude yeah yeah and I
was like you know what he might be right
because that's a couple of them private
means I was like I doing this this is
fun I'm authentic leave us we don't do
we don't wear leads we wear Levi's there
you go we're not doing that so that's
how it happened he brought me to my man
came mega and he introduced to the squad
and I did a podcast first I listened to
the podcast and then II know when you
always got do your homework and then I
said yo these dudes just talking gaming
so I was like you know what that's a
wheel and that's what I'm gonna do
because I want to affiliate myself with
solid peoples you know like I said like
like like I knew David was a was a
savage but he was established with what
structure
when he brought me to y'all and like I
said after that that dinner man I said
he did this is I mean you got a circuit
you gotta surround yourself with people
that you want to you know move within
progress and so people respect them and
they know they're not gonna bring people
around them that don't respect a self
and it's like a it's a it's a unity
that's what it's about
but I got a chance to meet you brother
obviously bet you I mentioned when we
had the dinner join shout to Megatron
he's up in there and Tim dog shout-out
to pickles listen we trying to set up a
next situation I was just hitting him up
in there yeah y'all had a Yo Gotti and I
was like we got to start to get our
little annual each together I was
figuring around January because you know
we almost finished with the packs
planning then January you know we're
squad up get our food on and then you
know go on into the year to figure out
exactly how we're gonna map out this
year and its content we're gonna bring
me you guys I'm still waiting for the
change but because at the end of the day
one thing I'm respected about you and
Lords what we do is that we outside you
don't say cuz a lot of dues no
disrespect they game and all that but
they're not out there you know saying we
know who's really outside that's it
right we don't pay that's I said we keep
it positive we didn't we don't pay the
Internet noise in the disrespect any
mind cuz we are here and gotta respect
that passion always good seeing you
bumping in you already know he three
packs all that good stuff we got to do
it up you know I'm booked for e3 already
call hotel okay
[Laughter]
so I was just talking to Megatron about
that Lincoln I'm making sure everything
goes right with that and we got a
telling you because you know you 100k
mega we all got a politic delilah HD
everybody that's out there especially
Cali family you know we gonna have their
welcome to this one and so lord meet
this now is the time that I asked the
question that famous question if you own
your squeeze so I need your top 5 video
game or franchises of all time number
Auto at this general no it doesn't have
to be ordered Jessie Garon could be the
view for one part what video game from a
series or convenient I get l-boogie you
know dare Gong well mm-hmm not forget
you know no you stop women game except
my buddy lemon on the show keeping it
real soul ever got I gotta bring it to
you man I need the five video games or
franchises of all time your personal
file don't have to be any order the
games that affect you the most
Mortal Kombat is G further halo halo
series okay that's Ritter uh God of War
series
really Oh Mario right now I do this poll
but yeah we got last week's poll results
are any people have spoken to the
question with the recent controversy had
these cops is not playing out here you
get it coming Ronnie wait a shower to
get all sir x-men to our super chat Tomb
Raider
she started 3d platforming that's what's
up so back to the poll out of the cops
are gone with the recent controversy
regarding Geoff Keighley is non
involvement with the game Award
nomination process do you feel there are
still ethical concerns in regards to
death strandings nine nominations the
winner of the IOP three way ILP poll
with 64% of the vote is the yes Jack
Geoff Keighley is founder host producer
with influence impropriety coming in at
second place your school takes a the
front Alert is coming for the poll
second place at 28% was know Geoff
Keighley
doesn't vote on nominations and this is
only an issue for fanboys or in last
place and only 8% was I don't care
y'all just man control and Jedi check
out Jedi and gears fire from the last
group so shout out to all the lords were
participating in the poll
Lord sovereign is this what you feel a
minute impropriety you got the heads of
Japanese publications in your game it
just happened to get a 10 like 10 out of
in the history of the whole public 8
hell no Keely maybe an innocent in this
I don't know but there's a lot of stuff
around the rest of it listen influence
like if you've messed with me right and
you want the panel and I compassion I
next grab your show dump like that kid
Jean Widow you can go what we will vote
so doesn't matter he was there he's
involved he needs to work on his
plausible accountable is explorable
liability or whatever just two weeks
before the game came out he turned it to
the deaf strand in math that I'm sorry
oh we're gonna be you're gonna be amazed
of the experience but you know what
rooms deputy sells 223,000 sales they
didn't even support the game I was
interested because yeah there was some
unrest we know about the flu thing but
we gonna move on because we got a lot of
show we got a lot to get into but I am
up so on controversy from Dominus let's
get those dollars going on in these
Twitter streets so to speak um yeah man
so basically you know he did an
interview with a survivor after XO 19
and this was in reference to virtual
reality it's whether it's gonna be part
of the project scholars so he said his
quote we're responding to what our
customers are asking for and nobody is
asking for VR Spencer said the vast
majority of our customers know if they
want a VR experience there's places to
get those we see the volume of those on
PC and
places he said it's not just that Xbox
players don't expect to have VR games no
Spencer says Microsoft decision to push
VR side for now is due to the fact that
nobody's selling millions and billions
of izakaya he's watching the program is
a million hey Phil this a pocketwatch
watching up to so you said we might get
there eventually but yeah that's not
where our focus is so this off kind of a
storm and a lot of VR supporters are
very upset with all Phil's comments you
know feeling was very dismissive you
know we had some other feedback in there
so before we get into that won't bring
it to Lord the meatiest man was Phil
Maximus Dominus a really expensive not
really okay any other questions I got
for you Lord let me do is that you know
the the point of contention from the
people on the other side that what VR
they say look one project Scorpio was
announced we got a clip Phil diamond is
saying this will also support VR
experience so people feel some people
feel betrayed
where do you stand on this whole VR
thing with Phil Spencer um I own a vo
and I got the PlayStation and I got the
Samsung which looks better than
PlayStation but we're not gonna go there
and do that I'm gonna say this for the
record let's go change between years of
announcement oh it's for financial gain
and he sees oculus to change the head
put a headset about four five arms the
questions they same thing they trying to
make it Wireless they trying to go here
everybody's there is nothing off via
triple-a title to draw the masses Xbox
they're just trying to get these studios
right they trying to get a first-party
gaming right they double A's the indie
style games be or shouldn't be Microsoft
focus because even though the
Playstations all about four million and
it's the top-selling VR has
Jessica's console people it costs so
much money on PC is ridiculous you have
to build a monster PC but when you look
at the whole picture is it financial
beneficial for anybody because they
don't have no killer game on no platform
that's sold millions and millions so
that's what you have to look at so so
it's like it's like it's a business
perspective you got two or three billion
dollar company on your head you got to
look at these two perspectives yes and
if you paid attention to any of those
announcement and xoxo a small group is
making that game not the whole team
right they are obviously working on
something else that's right you got a
look at these you can't just jump off
like yeah they're not doing what they're
supposed looking listen to what people
say is fair it's like your parents used
to tell you and do you learn stop
jumping out the window and look trauma
to discredit every six word that Phil
says so you
it's a level of sensitivity they
overreact in on the gosh I mean he's
bringing engaged XO 19 I haven't been
impressed with none of those um XO 19
was solid the super chair got a rebuff
dis whoa sir x-man super chat thank you
sir I do appreciate every dollar that
you send and your time to type something
in I wanna hololens come on Phil hello
lenses in the store go pay your for
grammar stop fraud you can go purchase
it for you right now is four grand go
see because me personally I was all dead
set on it I was dead set to running in
until a full Granberry of smack me in
the face and told me stay in your lane
brand availa
is right now you can have howling at
this very point right now before grant
might be on to something sir let's go
get but is it gotten right there right
now go put in the hololens
and then put it inside the cart and
check-out put check out watch your
wallet there watch your wallet check out
with you you'll hit that like button a
building he said I rather see these
studios get to work then VR just saying
but I'm gonna let lord lemon finish his
thought on this man um that was all
basically done I mean via is a very
sensitive subject and everybody will buy
it and then say oh I want do this it has
it has a great experience but you need
that right title like beat Sabre if you
need to share some ounces oh yeah oh
yeah I know about that be saber like
it's dope
but yeah
no wait no shout to stick to the file I
said which I have tried the hololens at
work and so far years ahead of any other
VR headset out there just the fact that
it doesn't use any wires is best all
right so let's get solving a building
man so obviously this is very
controversial some people feel very
strongly against Phil with this
statement you know where do you stand on
this law sir I mean I'm I'm right there
with with with lemon and we caught with
King I'm going to be first in line to
pick up all this stuff and I fraud it a
million times on VR like I just like and
it was just one of those things where I
knew I'll get it in the house I play it
a little bit and then it would be just
be collecting dust so I just decided
which is very rare for me I'm always
getting everything first and no no and
I'm good and then I've never had that
feeling like man I didn't get it man I
didn't do it and I was like so I get
that feeling where is it's when you look
at the numbers on on psvr right which is
the best-selling one out there because
like lemon said because the association
with playstation let's be real let's put
that in perspective now a hundred
million Playstations out there a hundred
million Playstations out there it's not
a hundred million our headsets out there
now Marvin they just they all sell for
200 bucks now during during the holiday
season frankly we're like three games or
something I don't think I don't think
they give you the Move controllers but
they give you everything else and like
five games right that'll start moving to
need a little bit just to have people
have it in the house and have and be
able to play it and experience it and
know what it is to experience it tell
you right now like when you like like
lemon said businessman when you look at
the Kinect the Kinect was an unqualified
failure Oh 10 million units yes so 10
million is a failure six million more
units then then a psvr has mmm that is
considered a success so the thing is
market they could do it on some sideshow
stuff but I know when they thought about
that they were thinking about a are once
they wants hololens came out and they
saw the middle ground right
Kuzma hololens is one in the spectrum
vrz others in the spectrum AR is right
in the middle where it's not quite how
it lands a little bit of both right
right
that makes sense for more for different
applications right where's educational
applications stuff that you can sort of
see using in the real world because
you're not completely removed from the
real world that keeps you at that middle
ground that makes sort of sense and even
Microsoft said okay we'll build headsets
in conjunction with other companies and
choose I think when it comes to
Microsoft now especially the Xbox brand
everything is choice right let's get
there welcome to the realm and we got a
super chat to hold on let's get pixel
big G finally so much a thank you
brother I have had PSVs has launched
it's solid and I still don't care about
it still impossible to play with my kids
around focus on games not gadgets and
then we got a new is that's the Louvre
that's my guy but have a boss move they
battle for the funniest bigs in that
chat ban salute but yeah imma let you
finish off if I give it a kick just like
you know maybe Phil admitted himself
maybe I could have worded it differently
but the truth is the truth is it's not
something that they're gonna focus on
now especially them they can't they
can't be seen to be focusing on anything
but games and perhaps point I feel you
like nobody's asking for this cartoony
looking stuff but at the end of the day
it's still a core game the Larry ask you
this though Slava just to play fair that
was bracket the counter-argument that
I'm seeing and I see a lot of some of
the chatter saying is that you know feel
is supposed to be about giving gamers
options right and to the main point of
contention RC and Islam there was one
particular Twitter user I forgot her
name but she got kind of bomb she she
went hard at Phil you know I'm saying
she was like I'm not getting that
project scarlet you guys lied and stay
pulled up the old project it'll come
with those fences saying VR experiences
will be supported so like what do you
say
people who say look you told me options
you want me to play with but you not
providing meet his options why don't you
diversify and give us this option in
so-to-speak
gonna buy it anyway she'll fraud I'm
lying then show me when you picked up
all other VRS that was available but
you're just picking out this one VR that
you upset with show me the VR that you
purchased because you wasn't able to
purchase the VR on xbox
you'll fraud I'm just gonna tell you Wow
solve the reality of it is that the
business when you looked at it if you if
if Microsoft with a look at PlayStation
right now and you had 50 million
headsets out there right that would
convince you okay mmm
there is enough of a market there for us
to invest age since they didn't invest
from the very jump either right they
would pull it up behind people right and
Microsoft doesn't like to do that they
just didn't they didn't go that right so
basically what you're saying is that he
their promised it but not a change in
focus
they changed the focus and that's it
like it I remember Todd Howard coming
out and showing you know Skyrim VR and
all that stuff I remember all that
listen if if you're somebody was super
excited just for that aspect of it I'm
at the point where Xbox I need them to
be as focused on core gaming as possible
don't don't don't let your eye stray
don't no no just I'm on all 129 yo get
your eyeballs ready so as y'all watching
guess what I got on my head does not
hooked up to my television see I'm no
fraud yellow oh please make this kind
please throw yourself in the bushes if
it's not available on one platform is
available on another you gonna talk
about viability in the marketplace
viability man marketplace Microsoft was
in a different place at that point of
time and telling you that what he did
promise you was that this stuff would be
available he also told you to power the
cloud right how long did it take for the
power of the cloud to show up it showed
up so you're gonna sit that you're gonna
wait for the video or experience they
did have headsets that was being made by
different companies that will use
Microsoft technology that will give you
that VR experience it's not valuable
right now you think we're supposed to
well they're supposed to launch a VR
headset in in the middle of a drought
with no games
we gotta have to have gained development
first y'all was crying before Microsoft
didn't have no game just crying before
they didn't have studios now they got
studios and they're making games but you
want them to split their focus going
into a new generation on VR are you
absolutely out of your mind
oh he is selling their old stock they
selling these wired up joints for this
cheap right now they're giving you every
game they got in a box for so they tell
you listen go buy this whack headset
with let me tell you from the firm from
the get-go out of all the headsets is
the worst all right any any one of those
Google headsets all those other headsets
is the absolute worst but it is the
best-performing headset because the
cheap man can afford it
during passive entry and you can go buy
this cheap headset to you you can go buy
a thousand dollar PC to run all for the
new headset you can't do that so okay
it's a viable option for people that
want to experience VR without really
taking a bath financially mmm like my
little musty mom's coming at you he says
what you're saying
Microsoft can't do both you say NATO
broke yes I'm saying that I'm saying
that my man just got to the table my man
just got to the big-boy table do you
know when you sit in there and
Thanksgiving y'all just had Thanksgiving
you have two tables right you have the
tables for the kids and the tables for
the adults all right so the table for
the kids filling them was sitting at the
table for the kids
they head down you know I know I could
get to the big table I know give me a
shot so Phil secretly plotted secretly
got his way to the big Table nine he's
sitting at the big debut think he gonna
risk going back to the little table and
by bringing up some VR crap that's gonna
fail
oh boy want nothing but wins he don't
want no losses so he don't need to hear
you know they they come out with some VR
experience this subpar they're gonna
they're gonna get destroyed for what the
same arguments people are having about
you know cartoony looking games in the
same arguments are gonna happen but soft
do you think that people are pocket
watching Marcus over saying why they
don't have the bandwidth to do both they
say Sony could do it how come Microsoft
you dig it they absolutely had the
bandwidth they just choosing not to
listen the Sony is not doing it they
don't have no games this year bro stop
acting up like you're seeing all these
VR games popping out y'all a complan I
mean they don't have anything they don't
even have original games this year
you're closing out the year with nothing
you're sliding into 2020 listen I'm
gonna tell you right now maybe y'all
went wrong maybe I decided yet maybe
y'all [ __ ] in the focus diversified your
portfolio in your stocks Phil if you
look that you was like I'm not gonna
make that same mistake why would I do
that
nobody on the team is yelling out we are
please I have never been to a Microsoft
event and somebody yelled out VR now
[Laughter]
one person said this you know what he
meant getting in box nobody's Yo Gotti
in him talking about y'all out here
except for the video there's nothing
stopping you from getting your VR
experience from PlayStation there's
nothing stopping you from getting your
VR experience from your PC
ain't it seem when you yelling out
hololens ain't nothing when I got asked
you this question but I got you loved it
so what'd you say King is the people who
don't own X boxes or whoa yelling you
know why this is easy for you to yell
out something that you ain't gone by
gonna start making Lamborghini y'all
gonna stop trying to make my man trip up
y'all upset you know when news is
winning and yeah he went in too hard why
don't he do something stupid
he's gonna do something stupid just so
he could fail so you can laugh now you
all still stand behind them you won't
hate just like those three little hate
signs that we got in the chat I know all
three those dudes we got those all those
three thumbs no no no those other guys
with the thumbs up that's the Phills
right over the winner I got before I get
leverage shout out the sleepy table to D
with the file I was super chat he goes
dan that chat was far oking I hope you
dust it off that psvr off before you put
it on your crap coming at UK he said
finally borrows comments we're
interesting on Xbox did they need to
innovate more that cloud isn't
innovation is not with the company why
do you want that up to the realm you
brought that in here and I'm gonna tell
you what I don't care what you think
about a company when you no longer
with the company I'll talk about they
need to diversify maybe you needed to
diversify but understand not say no
shade at him you broke this up so I'm
just gonna defend this part you're not
there you don't care
concentrate on what you're working on
and they're gonna concentrate on what
they working on let's see who's more
successful at the concentration any
other game and platform where you see
these dudes come up the bushes and
somebody else have they that we're
putting it behind a paywall because they
financially strong now that's what this
augmented reality for microscope go
ahead 4x there your wall but it's 4x you
know you wanna play with the big boys
you gotta work off play harder yeah I'm
gonna have multiple consoles and games
this is what you got to do but don't
come and start hating because you think
it's behind your imaginary pay wall no
is your wallet that's the problem it's
hard to be these collectors we are
pissed it's a hard it's hard about 3 or
4 4k movies a weekend in games you in a
truck my Black Friday wasn't that good
because I got every goddamn thing you
know I did get man for 20 bucks but ok
let me jump in this this is good this is
good I I definitely hear where kick is
coming from King might be order so you
know
say he's a little ggressive but he my VI
resulted but let me know you can sit
there and say I'm a damage control from
old boy
listen I'm gonna say this cuz you you're
not going yeah no no no is this is
somebody in the chat that said it
alright but I'm not gonna say because
it's not in green but I'm gonna say this
right I'm gonna tell you this this part
right there I came up with feel Dominus
Maximus Spencer oh right and the reason
why I came up you can say I'm damage
controller for boy yes yes if you go to
my xbox pitches me and fill in that
picture all right and every e3 I go to I
get a chance to talk to him and share my
views on what's going on and what I
think he did so far and when you look at
a measure of a man you can look him in
his eyes right now when somebody got
something to hide they look away you
look you dead yeah he talks to you dead
in your eye and you can understand what
he's saying right not one Sony exact
that I get a chance to chop it up with
when I got a chance to talk to mark
Cerny he ran out the back if anybody
wants a oh you know you cap it fulfill
so what but I'm gonna tell you this at
no point in time did he run away from my
conversation actually he pulled me
closer said nah I want to hit a no real
he said I want to know from you King was
really good and I got back from on that
real quick shout to Smitty super chat
man there's a lot of pocket watches
watches in the chat please leave that to
the Lords had to get this one I won this
shot out to the room when we hadn't run
before Lord Matt could tell of the NPD
group and he had some interesting tweets
in response to this whole day basically
said the data suggests that Phil Spencer
is spot on with his assessment of vr
gaming he said perhaps someday the
market can develop but it's been years
and the overwhelming majority of gamers
consumers just don't care rounding error
of rounding error for games it's a tiny
niche and then he continues on he's
saying it's cool tech but it's the
definition of niche and he was saying
out of all the possibilities of gaming's
future the market opportunities are
breaking down barriers for players
making
easier for people to play in to connect
with others vr by its very nature
doesn't work that way
vr can be a successful niche but it's a
small one so he's jumping behind field
this is the mark he has the data like
these are people shout out to my boy
stealth south 40k he doesn't market
research research he's saying that
gamers don't want it so it does feel
like there is a vocal minority that is
yelling the loudest for this when the
numbers suggest the opposite and the
last thing I want to shout my boy um
Brian McCaffrey he basically said the
same thing he said look I can't disagree
with Phil's here he says on far as VR
for the Scarlet he said while I applaud
the efforts of Sony oculus valve the
numbers aren't there after three and a
half years Phil will no doubt agree that
the new Xbox Studios bandwidth is better
spent on games for scarlet not VR and
that's pretty much where I'm at I mean
at the end of the day it's like this I'm
a techie I love tech I'm never gonna
disrespect any type of new innovation
but it has been three and a half years
it still has not caught on like wildfire
it is I didn't even even the
Playstations your own success it's still
less than what the Xbox did would
connect so to speak so you got that
aspect then the whole thing is like
price point right it's an additional
peripheral now so now you're telling
developers to make something for it
right even if you have a massive hit
like an astro bar or what-have-you right
you're now this little subset of that
install base that now you have to hope
also that only they pick up the
peripheral that they caught your game so
that's another risk from a business
standpoint and to be honest as much as
Microsoft gets a lot of flack for the
Xbox one let's not forget you know they
kind of did it right by having they were
successful with Kinect on 360 then in
order to Xbox one to me the smart play
was making Xbox one Kinect in every box
so this way you guarantee the masses
have it but the next take off now I'm
not gonna say you know Kinect is the
same level as view I'm not gonna do that
but the thought process was correct that
you want the entire store be and max
they'll fail so again I get the logic
behind saying look we
we bashed you know Microsoft where's the
games where's the triple-a bangers not
invest in studios you don't say yes do
they have the resources probably to do
both
absolutely but me personally I would
rather them invest all their resources
to fixing games triple-a bangers
I want that before I want vo on take a
risk because to me that's pocket watch
it yeah they can do it but what would
you rather have
especially when the competition that's
supposedly successful eight is four
percent isn't it like four percent off
one of them okay yeah all right so
that's the Brabant to fight off super
chat dear Phil I wrote you but still any
calling my pager in my home phone that's
the [ __ ] Wow well bugs tend out Wow tell
us what you that's what I'm saying all
these people crying ain't buying a damn
[Laughter]
look it's just a bad business model at
the end of the day look I play VR it's
fun I play some game called arc or
something from rebellion I played them
baby saber joint lemon that she was
talking about join the fire but let's be
real to like be stable is low-key Dance
Central with savers doing this you know
say it's just that again it's 3d oculus
no shelter you bar to shelter lady
somebody let me try to anyhow it was
amazing but it's just like you know
again it's a very you know what it
remind me of King it kind of a mommy a
3d TV wave you know that's you know what
I was going to talk about that because I
have a 3d television downstairs I have
one upstairs and um oh oh yeah yeah
upstairs I didn't have inside deliver
because they they didn't put it in the
technology like you not but the fact is
I brought those those glasses and each
glass this was $250 each yeah so I got a
family of five so I had to buy five
glasses right all right so y'all do the
math on that then do the math for the
television then
math one or the 3d movies didn't take
off right you know think so I'm the
stupid dude that's it man through all
this money on his pocket yeah I wanted
experience in my opinion of the $50 to
take the family out the goal to see a
movie there's money no I was the flowers
the tester right you know what happens
when you when you test stuff out yeah
you're not the minority cuz you're
crying because you want to be supply
with games and stuff like that how many
people that brought the PlayStation VR
is upset at this moment right now
because they've been playing the same
five games for the past four years I
just I wish I don't feel the tech is
necessarily all the way they need to be
completely untethered it takes a lot of
resources another they have to they have
to figure out arm tracking because a lot
of people don't like the fact that they
use it you know everything is these
detached hands and you're not not doing
arm tracking and stuff like that full
body tracking obviously people had you
know I think it's out there for purchase
that treadmill thing that allows a
person to do it but exactly this is what
I'm talking about it doesn't none of it
they haven't gotten the tech to a point
where it's it's viable as a commercial
product that it can be purchased by just
not anybody here's the other thing for
like this people forget to is that
there's so many different VRS right the
market still hasn't come together where
there's a unified platform that this is
the de-facto like this it's still
segmented you're not saying this games
games you get there I know we gonna get
in there half like Alex's stuff that's
the next topic but my point is until we
see something like that right there's no
killer app right and to me one
collaborating gonna be enough you said
you need multiple bangers to be like
okay this is where it's at you know
saying and to me it's still not this I
can't get man out what I think the issue
really is and solve you nailed it people
are more mad at how it was worded as
opposed to the react if you look at the
reality from a pure business you know
stop pocket watch that makes no sense to
invest that heavily in
something in the market that is it
thriving that big right so my point is I
think the issue they have with him is
that he said nobody and you know say and
that he probably could have worded a
little better psyche nobody want that
joint focus my man is focused I don't
want to unfocus Phil heating for you
here's what he said because shout to my
boy Paris she blahblah bump in every III
of my destiny brother you know he said
he actually responded to Phil and he
said look Phil I don't think the issue
is Xbox focusing on building up their
games now and he said it was the way you
VR was dismissed by you as a novelty not
worth pursuing when it's clear there's a
huge triple a investment by valve Sony
blah blah blah then Phil responded back
to Paris and he said look fair feedback
I've said publicly I love how our
industry has pioneers AI physics 3d for
a reality check virtual reality AR you
said but for us it's about focus on our
innovations right now he said he's
placing great video games he said it's
just not our focus with Scarlett at this
time so I can't get mad at the man
saying and he's not closing the door
completely right now trying to get my
man off his Dean you're trying to trick
my man up while he run it to the finish
line
[Music]
boy it to the segue right into it to
solve right now man so right now what
away jag is TV and the lowest bow back a
beggar salute brother you know what I
got to give a big shout-out to Kate mega
because him lemon and 100 I'm 100 came
over to the compound and he will use the
old way out in Calabasas oh you know
people he was in Calabasas he's mad fall
he was away from
we still love y'all $75 it was like
because solve this is your topic
obviously half-life Alex you know I'm
saying this is a lot of rave review a
lot of people are talking about this and
some people feel that this may be this
could be the one so let's get to it man
man I love half-life absolutely love
half-life I know lemon probably played
the original at PC gamers King of course
like that you know if you play we had a
PC back in the day of you in a PC game
and when half-life came through it was a
revelation and then half-life 2 even
more cuz half-life oh really
I mean it introduced the world to steam
obviously mmm-hmm physics in a game like
for the physics engine in half-life 2
the source and then it is freaking
ridiculous so semi valve has always held
half-life in on this pedestal where says
we're not coming out with another
half-life unless it's another
transformative experience right and the
closest thing to that is we are because
beyond that I personally feel that you
just do a great first-person shooter to
be fine but no I wanted to take it to
another realm VR so we have half 5 Alex
which is set in between the events of
half-life 1 and 2 mm-hmm arguably the
best character in the half-life universe
Alyx Vance is fantastic I love her so my
thing is my question is do you think
this gonna move the needle we've just
talking about the viability in VR right
is this gonna move the needle at all
because they have been since the
announcement of the game Valve's index
headset and and and hand motion
controllers have sold out mm-hmm they've
been spikes in sales for the oculus
mm-hmm
and I don't I don't think it's coming to
place I don't think it's happening VVS
part 2 we have been in sales in all the
VR headsets available on the market
right now since the announcement of
half-life Alec so do you guys think this
is gonna move the needle at all or is it
again I still personally feel this
thing but I think it move the needle a
little bit because half-life how
parently name still has some cash a
lemon in the building man you have a
chance of seeing half-life Alex the
record is a half-life lover that serious
dead anymore I would love to see you
come back what they're waiting too long
basically it's like you wait so many
years
half-life might be dead and then you're
gonna stick it on something that most
people like I want half-life but I don't
want no damn VR oh not only do you gotta
spend big money to play this game you
got a hope that you enjoy it and like
the PR experience it's too many
negatives I'm not with that should've
been our option it should have been an
option we bringing out this half-life
but if you have a VR and get the bonus
experience it's like it's like with Ace
Combat mm-hm
it has a VR mode in it on Final Fantasy
15 has a VR mode separately from the
game you don't make that type of
franchise which they trying to hit a
grand slam which would ahead of
grandstand and gave people an option
you don't just force them into an
ecosystem not gonna work they coming for
as they say eight million views on
YouTube
jeez how much gears had only find a case
eight million gold cut off oh shut up
put gears up like gears is the talking
point for are you copping or you copy
see this is the thing like everybody
looking at everybody's pockets but they
own how are you poppin man this is a
bunch of boxes in need happen are you
running now buying day once asking
everybody else
eight million are you part of the eight
me
are you calling but this is the question
because I'm so sick and tired of people
talking all this big money talker but
when it's time to put a big money stuff
these day disappear
so my question is this cuz everybody hit
me
yeah when I'm going to put our oldest
catch of course that's a true cost 1,300
okay so did you go get it right now go
get it right now it's on eBay right
magazine no longer sideshow Oh get
you're not gonna do it so just stop
acting like y'all care about this disc I
just want to talk and fine everybody
wanna be hurt at this point she nice he
gonna take a loan out people get well
you know what and I want to see the
pictures of your loan system because I'm
gonna tell you right now I'm not gonna
go buy something separate to play a game
that [ __ ] came out years ago but now
that y'all want to push a technology no
because just this is all they doing they
had the game already on the side they
said you know what making VR we're gonna
push this technology so we can cram them
in the head and get all we can get no
you don't like he said let me said they
going for a home run they're gonna
strike out this is a strike out those
are the enthusiasts exactly are not that
many enthusiasts they have you have to
be an enthusiast for half life at this
point right and the thing is like lemon
said is like the the people that love
half life are older dudes already right
and if you've been in dudes it's like
that you probably have a headset already
so this isn't moving the needle now
regard I mean it is maybe people have
already purchased headsets that want the
new index because of but have the new
tech or whatever isn't this a new
headset from them that they're pushing
name is from them but it has also pushed
the I you know cuz the new oculus I
forgot what it's called to go or
whatever the winners are we're don't
work it's impersonal yeah the quests
there you go so it's pushed all headsets
that have confirmed that they're gonna
have the game on there some push sales a
little bit in that regard specifically
the index you know they're gonna talk
about their own head say
they say that once sold out specifically
because of the new tracking tech right
right that everything is on the on the
headset itself it's there it's made a
lot easier
there's no but the thing is that I agree
with learn when it comes to the
half-life name
they've always held this this this
series on a pedestal and they it seems
like they've always said like we're not
doing another one unless we're really
moving the needle on something right
like I said the first one story telling
right the first one retelling the
first-person shooter game the second one
was all about the physics and so with
everybody questions what is the third
one
why couldn't you just look at it and be
like okay how do we continue to improve
the first-person shooter genre what can
we do to add it not they were just
looking for the next big thing to sort
of attach it to right and to me when
they released the original vibe that's
when you come out with the half-life
game yeah all the time because you're
saying you're saying to the public we're
not confident enough in it to put to put
what we consider to be our marquee
franchise mm-hmm so it's like it just it
feels like the people that love
half-life and are willing to make this
investment I'm gonna be there and
they're gonna love it
if they're gonna move the needle
generally no my hope is that what my
hope is it just they make more regular
half-life dick I want to see a regular
half like game that's what I want to
know what all of these VR companies are
sitting in the offices doing in these
board meetings what game can be make to
get people in everybody we need to kill
the title and follow PlayStation via you
know this VR games coming out every week
they support I mean it's it's crazy but
ain't nobody buying soul of this podcast
chat it's a civil war to chat right now
y'all don't even know like it's a I'm
talking about the Christopher ha L bugs
charted P yo Philly they going aid right
now dizzy all of this it's Christmas
going right back
but anyway look I'll jump it man it's
like I saw the trailer I'm gonna front
make it look kind of cool to be and I'm
saying like that with the hands and all
that you see because already grabbed the
bullet off the gret dress and you put
the individual join the clip and all
that like it looked fire you don't say
it's just that again is one of those
things like like y'all sample for you
know is it going to be to kill AB are we
can sit there and view it and say it
look fine and eight million people could
say yo is it but are they gonna commit
and to this point we still haven't seen
it so until we see it you know and maybe
this does start a trend of this being a
killer app and then more other games
like this follow suit but for right now
you know I'm not there personally I'm
not running out to go get it you don't
say it and I just think that on the
place that you need to jump on this
though I think in place that you're
smart PlayStation VR part to you make
sure this is on your platform and I'm
saying because you might thing is you
have to do if I'm PlayStation and cuz
shot to shoot hey I know he's shot a
little shot back at feel like sometimes
you gotta make my paper though I respect
that I was a good shot you know so what
to me what I feel they need to do they
need to keep in mix one fire to your
whole team being in the bushes and you
the last man standing
you talk about making things nobody want
you they gonna make something you don't
want
unemployment you know I think if
PlayStation was smart they need to
double down right like almost like you
see a Lulu not that this is a weakness
in myself but you got it you got it you
got a mere them like because I noticed
if you look at the places into their
account they got VR pinned at the top
you do all that had nobody buying it
they got a hundred and twenty five
million people and you know the early
opposite mean the foolish
you see the foolish is you see the
foolish on the foolish I went out and I
say yes let me get this and you know
what really happened these wires what
happened and then you know going in and
and in the earlier I got the early one
that didn't do the switchover you had to
do all this other crap with it
with the new one that really pissed me
off that's when it really got thrown in
the bushes
you know I saw when they came up with
the new one and I was mad that I didn't
have to switch over because I went to
brought the pro where the pro was
supposed to make it stronger it was
supposed to be a better listen I tried
to support y'all as much as possible and
you write sometimes you make stuff that
nobody want honestly I really didn't
want it I really didn't need it and me
not playing it showed me how much I lost
I lost a lot of bread and I can't put it
on eBay to sell it because the shipping
and handling and all that other stuff
I'm just gonna keep it as a relic
so people is a warning sign for
Microsoft so on the show i'ma show Phil
anytime feel one think about doing that
I'm I sent my picture of my joint in the
bushes so he can just stay focused on
making games like even the things that
you mentioned cog that stuff about like
loading the gun and stuff like that it
looked cool so cog that's been done
already it's been done on Neo Geo I was
before I give it I will say this out the
WCF tech I believe CC Tech they had a
poll and they were actually their
editors were debating and they were all
saying what you guys are saying they
would like to half-life fans they
basically the question was posed to them
is like after seeing this does this
interest you now and getting this get a
gaming after seeing half like Alex and
the consensus was look it's cool but
they were kind of saying what let me say
I almost wish that there was a dedicated
verge instead of this mandatory thing
and people were saying like yo I'm
interested in but not to that point that
this is gonna be a breakthrough
he said granted I love the half-light
games I basically grew up with them but
I'm just not into VR never been never
will I get sick people talk about motion
sickness no saying virtual reality
didn't win me over and I don't see it
happening to Alex either
I would have preferred half-life 3
instead so people are upset that this is
an exclusive thing and they just don't
like video yo cog I bet you this happens
I bet you after half a year go by in
that joint don't sell did
come out regular version get Alex that
you could play everywhere now without
the VR and you can really have the true
experience you supposed to have I know
you know I believe Rhys was a VR game
initially mmm that game I believe super
Lucky's tale was a VR game initially
there are some games that you are you
start to see come over when it's not
gonna be interesting that's all I'll let
you finish them anymore
amen I just did to me it's it's not
moving the needle I'm glad half-life is
coming back and they have said they're
doing more half-life stuff but they
haven't said what that is um but again I
just think I just think they need to
bring this they need to bring this
franchise back down to earth and
understand what people loved about the
franchise and expand on that
I'm just glad valves making games no you
know overall let's see what happens but
this again this is a niche thing it's
not really gonna move the needle like
that but you know but I guess beggars
can't be choosers right
beggars could just continue to beg me
and look at something else and go eat at
that damn portal because I'm not gonna
get it I'm sorry I'm just not gonna
purchase I waited for this day like I
waited for that day with anthem first of
all for every way I don't know well I
know attic was built by anyway for all
you frogs especially the frauds on this
panel they say yo I'm gonna go and I'm
gonna go purchase idiot this is for you
everybody move away I move around that
dude Delilah
HD before I go in oh wow with the
trailer switch a half-life Alex looks
great but the masses wanted a
traditional game which was Phil's point
regarding VR in general you know what
you baby on the subject
to the realm much appreciated see you
soon and Kelly Delilah
yo listen man alright so that's right
the top topic is stadia offer and
refunds the people catching out these
stadia Pro joints that's catching fire
shout out to the catch
yo this is the bar none the worst launch
in the history of video game launches
ever shout out to Phil bogus being in
charge of all it is and I'm glad you
came out with the red clown shoes so
everybody could see cuz everybody
thought yo King is he's a fraud
King isn't I listen I've been batting a
thousand on the show y'all dude I told
you don't mess with anthem y'all didn't
listen you're winning got it
what happened bushes I told you don't
mess the stadia it don't look right
something looking funny in the light and
then when I saw them bring out bogus I
definitely walk straight away from me
I'm cousin remember I preordered I took
away my pre-order when I saw his red
sneakers it was a red flag dilemma yo
you know what it was over I got from
round net boy I don't see his face I
don't see no tweets I don't see anything
I want to know yet no we don't know are
they offering cuz I'm looking and like
are they offering return refunds returns
on the actual yes subscription itself
cuz I know there's an issue where people
bought supposedly there was there was
their free games every month people
bought the pro right and then people
bought those games not knowing what
games
we're getting so they had agree from
people who actually have Pro but paid
for those games but I haven't seen
anything that they're refunding the
actual stickers so for the people that's
actually purchased in the joints caught
fire and the people that don't exactly
want what the experience is yeah 14 day
return policy that you can send that
dream back so a lot of people has been
lining up shipping me joints back even
the burnt up ones they've been shipping
it back and also it's the problem with
buying the duplicate free games like if
you hit a free game and you go out and
you purchase the game people was
wondering why am I getting charged for
this game is supposed to be free you
know so I see it as a terrible
experience from a hardware software and
delivery service all the way through
it's been it's been a train wreck when
it comes to what I don't understand is
why are these chromecast ultras
overheating when when it's doing what
the chromecast like it's just streaming
video so that's what a chromecast does
why is it to my boil enema in digital
foundry when they was like they not
doing the 4k 60s primes I told you this
is the thing they didn't tell the masses
that when it comes to the for casein
remember this is built on Linux right so
the teams behind these individual games
have to specifically put work into the
game to get aim to get it to run on
Linux and then to be get it to run at
that top tier right everybody's
impression was that this is all on
googles and right it's on stages and the
server's there's they're shooting out
the best possible quality game from
their server and if you're paying X
amount here whatever it is you will get
that no the work has to come on the
developer side all right they don't want
to put the time and money and resources
it's a given it wasn't a half according
to their messaging I so he came out with
the red shoes they say yeah he
the to say he had the Xbox 1x he had the
ps4 Pro and teraflops of and our system
is adaptable so whenever they level ups
we could love hello but I'm just like
whoa why it's like that and then when it
comes down to it now you're like oh now
or God in them it was developed because
it is lemon now I know you got a 10
grand television in your house right now
and you put your little chromecast in
your joint on the side right and you
come back your joint on fire they go
reverse my problem so you got this big
burnt scorch mark a browsers gonna do 40
60 a browser really since when the
technology changed out of a web browser
to stream a game seven gigs a month
capping people out it buggy man did but
hold on let me let me ask this question
this is a real question X cloud is not
the problem that's not a problem they
can date this that's like a Bentley
versus a Volkswagen that's not even a
situation here the situation is they
have the own problem stadia it's its own
problem they came on and said our
streaming service this is and it's not
yeah
games you pay to the surface whatever's
on angulas that's the first problem
Wow problem is vo what game you gonna on
stadia that you don't currently own
today hold on real quick
Smitty Smith with the files of jet stay
there sorry your 4k sixties in another
castle
[Laughter]
another thing another thing that they
promised right they said no updates ever
right you know you know NBA 2k 20 was
what downloaded the update the other day
somebody got it
it was update like you would have on
your console oh yo you also saw that
digital foundry exposed them and told
what what system they have in the
background right number when they was
saying that um they joint is 10
teraflops yeah and it was big it will is
not just like a beatin we telling you
this is gonna be the greatest action
movie ever stopped you know I'm saying
they're gonna tell you anything in the
previews that the production that listen
anybody that believed that and I ain't
gonna shout out my cup of my homies
uh-oh just go it's not gonna happen
technology has not changed to the point
if you notice Esther I don't even talk
about resolution just say listen
just play the game on your phones on the
front 720 yet come on yeah they not even
listen this is a portable situation you
don't want 4k portably don't burn your
battery out like like in New York in our
area we have cable vision we don't have
caps we don't have none of that but
outside to note those certain areas
except it's in the our dues it capped
off in the first 30 minutes how'd you go
quite anything that you had your cap
already Turner issues for me what this
showed me is that everybody is sitting
back Sony Microsoft Amazon they just
provided the blueprint of what not to do
I mean they still got a chance to turn
around but it sold like I said the price
point the games you're never saying and
then obviously living up to all the
promises and all the cool features that
they were talking about nobody like yo
you can interact with the youtuber they
don't have the achieve
it's so behind it's such a it literally
feels like they're the beta and X cloud
is the finished service but it's
actually the opposite it means some [ __ ]
recently you doesn't Google on Android
right so why would you limit it to one
from gas what I'm saying move for gay
trying to push Dave specific for all 10
all 12 people that got us pixels are you
serious and then it's like okay you you
also limited to the chromecast yes I
thought she was able to take it on
anywhere you're tethered to your PC is
so many other negative that they didn't
come out with people was not expecting
this onslaught of negative press this
awesome of bad service this onslaught of
not providing anything you promised
anything it's like they did what they
promised Johnny do these do is its top
20 people got pictures stadia is just
looking spooky I don't know what else to
say about it I just want to know how
many people in the chat returned a joint
or still got it and they're having a
good experience just put a one in the
chat if you got it and you having a good
experience put two in a chat have you
returned it which is real quick around
the round table real quick Black Friday
has come a lot of deals moving forces
entered age of the file I see the bushes
in the chat yeah I see them emojis
that's funny
but um yeah man so look real quick
there's Attucks topic just want to know
real quick what did the Lords of the
realm cop anything for Black Friday so
let's start with meet the instance I
know you said early you got everything
that did anything survived black fire
did you copy anything
oh back oh oh you got many No
um I'll be bringing a video out I just
ordered one of those 15.6 li Powell
monitors I will be playing it's cloud
everywhere attached to attached to my
phone um I can't
yeah I can't wait to do that I ordered I
got that it was $280 I've got a 109
Black Friday Amazon deal Oh
oh my god I got mad you know put a crib
to create create I blew on a blue a lot
of money on an onslaught of goddamn 4k
movies boy I can't wait to get that
screen know to test s cloud put it on a
hood of my car listen with the $2
supercharged this was a rush they scared
a tense crowd talking about stayed here
oh my this is true yeah my man JD gamer
with the file a super set I just got to
say it I like VR and I wish Xbox had it
but if it's a choice between great games
and VR VR is all the way in the bushes
[Laughter]
no hall whatsoever I Sam is lemon like
all them games like for me like I said
in like the the switch the switch lights
that I got for monies and nephew I got
that earlier when they first dropped so
that's that and when it came like just
just look at it deals that are cool like
I'm never one to advocate to get us a
console the year before new generation
is gonna drop right well I mean what I
did see was that that base ps4 with the
three games that for 200 that's cool
like if you have not jumped in that's
the perfect place to jump in on that
like everything else I honestly I know I
know we know we got those those stream
decks
from Amazon on the people but beyond
that like honestly like I look at just
looking at the list of games just
running downs I got that got that got
that got that damn what it does make me
feel bad is that I purchase all of these
games that I could before King I think
you did I think let me say the same
thing you know it's crazy okay it's like
this is the first Black Friday because
of services like game pass literally
everything it was really no sale I could
get like I was like damn I got this I
got I think the only thing I picked up
was like cuz Tekken 7 is on X clouds on
my team I played second in a minute and
he what I got the extra character so I
pick up like some DLC something for load
sheep but oh it's like the year of this
services kind of cute my Black Friday I
didn't really need to get shout to wrap
the arm the hardcover the shampoo that
was it that was literally and it's only
because that's why I had this exclusive
you couldn't get this in the where else
that was the only reason why I did it
but other than that I really wouldn't
purchase anything for back where was you
at with it okay well um I didn't
purchase anything I I'm when I had to go
get a switch for a friend but a little
sales on those switches mean on Nintendo
do Nintendo's not about lowering their
prices for anyone go go buy a Wii U
right now you're paying full price a new
edition like it just came out yesterday
they don't care um but I'm a gold today
and for winter solstice I mean I'm gonna
pick my son up my 8yo sanam get him an
Xbox one sad Edition so that way you
know he can play because it comes with
fort money it comes with three games
something like that they have they have
it for 149 so then I have a couple of
negro bucks at home $70 ramiro bucks
over there so I'm going in and I'm gonna
pick him up the system for like 80 bucks
because you know he's on the honor roll
and they're talking about putting them
in high school and he's eight and he's
been you know he's a gamer he plays all
the way through he saw me as a sad
addition to me
I'm sad that it didn't come out at 149
at lunch I'm sad he wasn't wit game pass
I'm sad that it didn't have a lot of
things so it's the sad version sir
Sharda is a great singer and I'm not
gonna associate but I'm picking up that
I think he earned it you know so you
know yeah you get that but for Black
Friday like y'all guys say we've heard
everything services like X cloud and um
game pass
oh it's games that I want to go by I'm
afraid literally I'm scared to go waste
a dollar on a video game because you
don't know it's gonna come on getting
passed tomorrow like you you literally
go buy a game and it's out tomorrow no
I'm good ok super shout-out to stitch 66
69 with the night with the $10 super
chat so I was holding for a bit I got a
sad Xbox sold the Xbox VCR Edition oh
wow
oh gee and I got that Samsung cute LED
curve 1440p monitor from Amazon I will
never give so many money again that's
got money that's pretty much I'm gonna
say like I say game pass all these
services man it makes it hard to take
advantage of Black Friday like we used
to so we gonna wrap up with this poll so
new il people with Phil Spencer's recent
comments regarding VR when project
scarlet be more of an appealing purchase
to you if VR was more of an investment
the choices are a yes provides your base
options and don't backtrack on VR B
nobody is asking for VR
we wanted triple-a bangings instead stay
focused it's literally like Bob Odyssey
let's not let this distract you from the
real play out here nice dr streets the
nintendo lab OVR
IOP Twitter Lord Lu meatiest aka 108
dragons TV up in the room
finally wicked I know people find you
everywhere
can they get ahold you know what's going
on what's going on with your brother
1:08 dragons TV on every social platform
on the planet what you gotta do man I
keep it simple it's spelled the same
across all the board man I like to think
y'all dudes for having me it was a
pleasure a little bit and wait me and my
brother gotta do some things in these
streets and keep the focus you know I'm
saying oh you already know in New York
[Laughter]
preciate job always lit I'm usually a
[ __ ] on super chess to get my point
across so papillon gotta Billie rock or
every block salute my boy runaway dragon
again like I say see what you're doing
seeing your journey rising and then what
I again what I respect keeping it
positive brother you know where we came
from you know how we can keep it for the
easy views but you choose not to do that
and we guys are brothers like you all
the time and much love man coming
through we're gonna see you with the
shows and all that you know how we do
Lord
sovereign in the room
we're good about people find you but you
got no answer or so sure that's the Lord
to meet the estate first time I met
lemon we wait at the spot eating right
you know so I'm it I'm sitting on one
side right we had this little booth I'm
the smallest dude and
we have Megatron's limpid we have King
and I'm like and it can't come in you
know right so I'm looking around I'm
looking at being at the way to the you
can we put a jail it was elevated right
so you they would have been able to work
there was like a like a high-rise shout
out to the one but hanging out with
dudes man like honesty and when it comes
to New York guys man we try absolutely
always show love to one another man we
go out III sit at the table
I look at the menu I said oh they got
fried pickles I ain't no goddamn frog
because you buggin man we we kept
ordering them like potato chips no
that's when you okay everybody gonna
have this spot like that spot that I
took that too that's my spot so we're
gonna let me spot we don't go to
Megatron's problem go to [ __ ] spot we're
gonna go to your spot so you know and
they don't get a chance to get that long
you know you know the bill needs to say
about VR is the Xbox is laser-focused
provide the best games on its platform
possible and as that goal is
accomplished we can then see if we are
something we could do JD gamer
you know for real but yeah man so that
was funny to Larry for pocket watch in
fraud type of stuff going door Oh Oh
shots of breath mm which have people get
t-rex arms when the bill comes facts
turn the beat around first of all the
first of four more let me give a shout
out to my man 108 dragon my black
brother long overdue my man is in the
realm and he's in the room and he's
definitely got all that I want y'all to
look at his background I'm not sure to
look at everything all right I want try
to see what's going on over there that's
a true gamer mm-hmm
when he when he took off the shirt I
thought he was gonna do striptease they
had the purple nurple under and if
they'll understand if y'all follow us on
Twitter you understand what the purple
nurple was about but you know you see
the games in the background those are
games that he's played those are not
just posters that he went out and got
those are games that he played so
respect his pedigree because he's
showing you exactly what he do now if
y'all didn't know that this the juice
cup that he got in the furnace mixer you
know that product placing placement you
know everything that's meticulously put
out there here's Xbox stuff then here is
a PlayStation God of War for you frauds
out there they claim that he's just only
Xbox now if you did not notice that
laptop right there that's 5,000 you
wanna watch my man you're gonna have to
really pocket watching for sure alright
so listen I'm just saying that to tell
you that he's real he's authentic you
know and it's felt when we say to Millie
Rock if you go to his channel you
subscribe this channel go to 108 drag
his TV go to his channel right now
you're gonna see it his intro you know
when he's talking about gaming I'm with
him you know I rock with him I know it's
underused or it's overused for a lot of
people they say only associated with
real dudes you know real dudes just done
in actions okay you can see a real man
in actions you know and real dude don't
want nothing from you they offer things
to you and he extended his hand he
offered something to me and I partook in
my opportunity with him if I got a
chance to listen to the UM the basement
radio station that was that I'm telling
you his his his people that he was with
he was real there was a phony they
wasn't fake he didn't have that around
him and he doesn't associate that with
him so when you when you go to UM his
gaming channel his podcast all those the
real dudes all those the certified dudes
you know Kay mega 100 and and even on
bloody knuckles you know bloody knuckles
is a stand-up dude and and and you can
stand behind that stuff this community
is vast and it has great content and it
has great people he told you he was so
sick and tired of false information
being pushed forward that he had to get
out then he had to give you the real
because I look at him I had some
questions on what camera should I buy or
stuff that I should do
you know um he has vast knowledge and I
hope everybody that was in the chat
today that was on watching today will go
to his channel subscribe and and get a
chance to see what he has to offer to
you because if I'm associated with
dragons TV like I said please support
the Lords of gaming dotnet you already
know the articles are up there the mood
my man Lord sent Tory on and all the
finest scribes of the realm please we
appreciate the support the retweets the
likes all that helps us as we got big
things plan for 2020 so the more you
support Lords of gaming dotnet the
better it is the more things we could do
against little to the patient oh your
card yes let them know um for those
dudes that join the round today we'll be
having a video going out this week yes
that's only for you guys and you're
gonna get a chance to check those videos
out those behind-the-scenes videos that
that nobody sing yes for the subscribers
man so again this will click the like
again a patient appreciate y'all if
y'all want support that way you have
that option and also you have the option
it's supporting to join button by
hitting the join button you get those
badges based on your length of service
you can go from us from a peasant to
adjusted to a squire to a lord you go
see your joint change after length of
time as well as all the Flymo geez we
got more emojis coming so the more
subscribers you get to see you don't say
anymore fire we give you our man so
that's all I got the audio will go up
later it is time for football
I got CDs knowledge man right now this
baby's going down right put on the red
and gold yes sir I got four that ready
to go everybody enjoy your Sunday we are
out peace